APPRECIATE IT.
I WANT TO GET TO MY COLLEAGUE ON
THE HILL NOW.
RYAN NOBLES.
OUR CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT.
IT OFFICIAL THE HOUSE IS VOTING
TO HOLD A MEMBER IN CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT.
GIVE US THE LATEST ON THIS.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT, DON.
THIS PLAYED OUT JUST AS WE
PREDICTED AT 10:00.
THE HOUSE VOTED TO REPORT A
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT REFERRAL FOR
THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF AND A FORMER MEMBER OF
CONGRESS MARK MEADOWS.
THE FINAL VOTE WAS 222-208.
TWO REPUBLICANS VOTED YES, LIZ
CHENEY AND KINZINGER.
EVERY OTHER REPUBLICAN VOTED NO
AGAINST ALLOWING THE CONGRESS TO
ENFORCE THE SUBPOENA LAWS, WHICH
GIVES THE CONGRESS THE AUTHORITY
TO CALL SOMEONE BEFORE THEM TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF IT'S A
MATTER THAT THEY BELIEVE HAS A
LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE AND THE
COMMITTEE BELIEVES THEIR WORK IN
INVESTIGATING JANUARY 6th IS A
KEY LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY RESULT IN
CHANGES TO THE WAY CONGRESS DOES
BUSINESS AND THEN TO THAT END,
WHAT OTHER INFORMATION THEY FIND
OUT ABOUT THE ATTACKS THAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th.
THIS ISN'T A SURPRISE, DON.
THE BIG QUESTION IS HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO DELIBERATE WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WILL PROSECUTE THIS
CASE, WHAT WE SAW PLAY OUT TODAY
IS A RECOMMENDATION.
THEY WRITE UP A REPORT AND GIVE
THE EVIDENCE AND INFORMATION
THEY HAVE TO SAY THEY BELIEVE
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL HAS IGNORED
THE RULES OF CONGRESS AND NOT
ANSWERED A SUBPOENA CORRECTLY.
IT'S UP TO PROSECUTORS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
A PROSECUTABLE OFFENSE.
THEY THOUGHT THAT ABOUT STEVE
BANNON AND THE SITUATION IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT WITH MARK
MEADOWS BECAUSE HE WAS WORKING
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AT THE
TIME IN QUESTION BUT THE
COMMITTEE BELIEVES THERE IS
ENOUGH EVIDENCE THERE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SHOULD
MOVE FORWARD AND PROSECUTE THIS
CASE AND IT WILL GO TO TRIAL AND
MARK MEADOWS COULD FACE JAIL
TIME DEPENDING ON HOW THIS PLAYS
OUT, DON.
>> I'M JUST LOOKING, RYAN, THE
SWITC
SEVEN REPUBLICANS THAT VOTED,
THERE WERE SOME REPUBLICANS THAT
VOTED FOR CONTEMPT RESOLUTION ON
STEVE BANNON.
THEY DIDN'T DO IT THIS TIME.
WHAT IS THE REASONING HERE?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> I THINK THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS YOU'VE SEEN, NOT
A LOT BUT A HAND FULL OF
REPUBLICANS WE'VE SEEN FROM TIME
TO TIME THAT HAVE CROSSED PARTY
LINES FOR THESE ISSUES RELATED
TO JANUARY 6th.
EITHER TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF THE
IMPEACHMENT OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP WHO HAVE
VOTED TO FORM THAT INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
AN INDEPENDENT GROUP TO
INVESTIGATE JANUARY 6th BUT AS
WE'VE SEEN THIS PROCESS GO
ALONG, YOU'VE SEEN FEWER AND
FEWER REPUBLICANS WILLING TO
TAKE THAT STEP OF KIND OF
STICKING THEIR NECKS OUT AGAINST
THE PARTY'S BASE TO TAKE THESE
TOUGH VOTES AS IT RELATES TO
ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO.
THERE ARE SOME REPUBLICANS YOU
THINK FOR INSTANCE WHO VOTED TO
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP TWICE WHO
WAS ONE OF THE ARCHITECTS OF THE
INDEPENDENT COMMISSION BUT VERY
CRITICAL OF THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE WHO BELIEVES IT'S TOO
PART
PARTISAN.
EACH AND EVERY REPUBLICAN THAT
CHOOSE TO VOTE NO HAVE THEIR
REASON.
SOME SAY THEY DON'T BELIEVE THE
SUBPOENA POWER IS CORRECT AND
USING CORRECT I THINK OF NANCY
MACE OF SOUTH CAROLINA FOR
INSTANCE, SHE WAS ONE OF THOSE
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED IN FAVOR
OF THE BANNON CONTEMPT REFERRAL
BECAUSE SHE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
CONGRESS MAINTAINING THAT
SUBPOENA AUTHORITY.
SHE CHOSE NOT TO DO THAT
TONIGHT.
WE DON'T KNOW THE EXACT REASON
WHY.
BUT THERE -- A LOT OF THESE
REPUBLICANS IN THIS TRUMP ERA
FOUND THEMSELVES  IN VERY
DIFFICULT POSITIONS ESPECIALLY
IF THEY HOPE TO SEEK REELECTION
AND HAVE TO GO THROUGH A TOUGH
PRIMARY WHERE SOMEBODY LIKE
DONALD TRUMP CAN PICK SOMEBODY
OUT OF THE BLUE AND SAY HE
ENDORSES THAT CANDIDATE AND HAS
THEM RUN AGAINST THEM.
>> JAMIE HERRERA BEUTLER, THESE
ARE FOLKS THAT VOTED FOR THE
BANNON CONTEMPT.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK, FRED UPTON,
JOHN, ANTHONY GONZALEZ OF OHIO
BUT DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE MEADOWS
RESOLUTION.
RYAN NOBLES FOLLOWING THE
BREAKING NEWS FOR US ON CAPITOL
HILL.
WE'LL GET BACK TO RYAN FOR MORE
INFORMATION.
CHRIS IS HERE.
I WANT TO BRING HIM IN.
HE'S THE AUTHOR OF "THE GATE
KEEPERS HOW THE WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF DEFINE EVERY
PRESIDENCY."
THANK YOU, SIR.
JUST GOT THAT BREAKING NEWS.
GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
MARK MEADOWS BECOMING THE FIRST
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF TO
FACE CRIMINAL CONTEMPT CHARGES
SINCE WATERGATE.
WHAT HAPPENED?
HOW DID IT COME TO THIS?
>> THIS IS A HISTORIC MOMENT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN TWO YEARS BUT
A DAY OF RECKONING THAT MARK
MEADOWS RICHLY DESERVES.
THERE USED TO BE A STIFF COME
EVER COMPETITION FOR THE WORST
CHIEF OF STAFF IN HISTORY.
NO LONGER.
MEADOWS OWNS THAT TITLE BY A
COUNTRY MILE AND IT'S ALMOST AS
IF NOT CONTEMPT WITH WORST CHIEF
BUT WANTS DUMBEST CHIEF.
HE'S RELYING ON THIS ARGUMENT OF
PRIVILEGE, WHICH HAS TO YIELD TO
EVIDENCE OF A CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY AND ATTEMPT TO OVER
THROW THE GOVERNMENT AS LIZ
CHENEY POINTED OUT.
NUMBER TWO, HE IS BY THE WAY HAS
DELIVERED THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS AND EMAILS TO THE
COMMITTEE WHILE CLAIMING THE
SAME PRIVILEGE --
>> AND WRITTEN A BOOK.
>> AND BY THE WAY JUST RELEASED
A BOOK.
SO YOU REALLY HAVE TO WONDER HOW
HE COULD HAVE HANDLED THIS ANY
MORE THAN HE HAS AND SO HERE HE
IS.
WATCHING THAT, YOU HAVE TO
WONDER HOW SOMEONE WHO WAS ONCE
A MEMBER OF THAT BODY COULD
THROW AWAY NOT ON HIS REP TALGS
BUT MAYBE HIS FREEDOM ULTIMATELY
IN THE SERVICE OF SOMEBODY LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
>> ONE MUST ASK, YOU SAID ALL OF
THOSE THINGS, WHAT KIND OF
STRATEGY IS THIS?
IS THIS A STRATEGY?
IS HE TRYING TO HAVE IT BOTH
WAYS?
YOU SHOULDN'T HOLD ME IN
CONTEMPT AND FACE CONSEQUENCES
FOR THIS BUT ALSO, HEY, TRUMP
AND TRUMP SUPPORTERS, LOOK, I'M
DEFYING.
>> IF THIS IS A STRATEGY HERE,
IT'S WINSTON CHURCHILL WOULD SAY
IT'S EXCEEDINGLY WELL DISGUISED.
I DON'T SEE ANY STRATEGY HERE
OTHER THAN POSSIBLY BANNON
PANICKING WHEN HE DISCOVERED THE
TRUMP WASN'T AS EXCITED ABOUT
HIS BOOK AS HE WAS.
I THINK HE WENT INTO RETREAT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A STRATEGY THAT
CAN POSSIBLY WORK HERE.
I SAY I THINK HE'LL WIND UP
PROBABLY BEING PROSECUTED BY
DOJ.
>> YOU THINK HE WILL?
>> I THINK HE WILL.
I DON'T THINK THE PRIVILEGE THAT
HE'S SITING HERE CAN POSSIBLY
WORK WHEN YOU'RE THE SUPREME
COURT DECIDED IN 1974 BY A VOTE
OF 8-0 THAT PRIVILEGE HAS TO
YIELD WHEN THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
A POSSIBLE CRIME.
>> MARK MEADOWS WAS THE
FOURTH -- HE WAS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S FOURTH CHIEF OF
STAFF.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BUT HE'S SET TO BE THE CHIEF
OF STAFF THAT TRUMP ALWAYS
WANTED.
WHY IS THAT?
>> NO QUESTION.
HE TOOK IT AND MADE IT AN ART
FORM.
YOU KNOW, DWIGHT HISSEISENHOWER
MY MIND MARK MEADOWS IS THE YES
MAN.
THERE WAS NEVER A SCHEME OR EVEN
ILLEGAL PROPOSAL THAT MEADOWS
WASN'T HAPPY TO TAKE TO THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF OR
COMPLACENT IN.
HE FLUNG THE GATE OPEN TO THIS
STAR WARS BAR CAST OF CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS